So Allah says in the Quran, man is in
kas los except those who have
immala that there's no god but Allah and
no one else is worthy of worship. Imman
in all the messengers of Allah subhanaa
tala and Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is the last and final
messenger.
Imman in the books of
Allah. Iman in the
Akar, I iman in the angels and I iman in
destiny. These are the six pillars of
IM. So those who have belief number one.
Number
two, the righteous deed. You should have
righteous
deed and the best righteous deed is
salah. Then you
have then you have s fasting then you
have and so on and so forth.
The third category Allah says
is inviting people to
truth. That is doing dawa and doing
islah. When you meet a Muslim, correct
him. It's called Islah. When you meet a
non-Muslim, do dawa, invite him to the
way of Allah subhana wa tala. It's
compulsory. Without that you can't go to
Jenna. You may be a very good Muslim.
You may be five times a day. You may
have you may have the mark on your
forehead. You may be fasting in the
month of Ramadan. You may be giving
zakat. may have gone for Hajj but if you
don't do
dawa if you don't convey the message of
Islam to the non-Muslims according to
surah als you shall not enter
Jenna only dawa is also not sufficient
all four like very important iman
righteous deed dava andawas and the
fourth category
is inviting people to patience and
perseverance if anyone is missing under
normal circumstances you shall not go to
Jenna if Allah wants to forgive you if
you don't do dawa and put you in ja
That's Allah's
prerogative. But
generally one of the criteria besides
iman and righteous deed
is doing dawa and inviting people to
patience and
perseverance. This surah according to
Imam
Shafi may Allah have mercy on him. He
said if this surah alone was revealed
for humankind it would have been
sufficient for haya only this one
surah only one
surah and we read in empty number of
places those who have belief and those
who are they go to Jenna. In this verse
Allah
specifies the other verses right two
important aspects of righteous
deed
in there are basically two criteria im
and but two important categories of of
righteous deed is
dawa and inviting people to patience and
perseverance and Allah says in many
places including surah chapter number 18
verse number 107 and 108 that those who
have
believed and those who have done
righteous deed they will enter paradise
and will stay there
eternally and they would not want to
their desire would not be to take
anything in exchange. So Allah says in
surah chapter number 18 verse number 107
and
108 that those who believe me those who
are M those who are Muslims and those
who righteous deed they'll go to Jenna
eternally forever this is ultimate
happiness forever and you would not
desire to exchange for it anything once
you enter
Jenna you won't like to desire to
exchange for
it Allah says in Imran chapter number 3
verse 110
Oh ye Muslims, ye are the best of
peoples evolved for mankind. Allah has
given us an honor and calling us Muslims
as the best of people. Whenever there is
honor, it is always followed up with
responsibility. There is no honor
without responsibility. So when Allah is
giving such a great honor to us and
calling us the best of
peoples, isn't there any responsibility?
The reply is given the same
verse. Because we enjoy what is good and
we forbid what is wrong and we believe
in Allah. If we do not enjoy what is
good and if we do not forbid what is
wrong, if we don't do dawa, we are not
fit to be called as Muslims. We aren't
fit to be called as umah. Dava is
compulsory for every Muslim. It is f